cutter is asking the United States to
help lift the recent boycott of that
country the action is led by Saudi
Arabia cutters foreign minister met with
Secretary of State Rex Tilson yesterday
so listen wants the Saudis to continue
to talk in good faith the Saudis won't
cut her to comply with their list of 13
demands by this weekend in the foreign
ministers first u.s. interviewer
Margaret Brennan asked about accusations
by the Saudis their allies and President
Trump that Qatar finances terrorism
President Trump stood at the White House
and said at the very highest levels of
the Qatari government there is support
for terrorism was he wrong well it's
absolutely wrong I thought is committed
to countering terrorism so when the
president says at the very highest
levels of your government you're saying
that doesn't happen it doesn't happen
that never happened them so it's not
doesn't happen anymore that's never
happened it was wrong yes Senate Foreign
Relations chairman bob corker says he
will not approve u.s. weapons sales to
any gulf countries until there's a path
to settle the diplomatic crisis that
would jeopardize president Trump's 110
billion dollar arms deal with Saudi
Arabia